[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody um welcome to the
cnr committee for august to remind you
we are
live stream audio live stream so we'll
be very decorous
as is our want welcome dan we have no
apologies
um no any conflicts of interest we have
none thank you
item three confirmation of minutes
someone like to move that dan moves
robbie seconds
any comment of accuracy changes all good
i'll put that then all those in favor
please say aye against carrie
matters arising item four anything out
of there
phil yes i just wondered
on page six the food forest license
i gather from the tuahiwee
kaya poi to a heavy board meeting that
still hasn't been
sorted yes is there any update yes um
it was raised last night it wasn't
officially at the meeting or
unofficially at the meeting
last night and chris i asked chris where
the hell is that because
it's a year more or less since it was
meant to have started to roll over and
it's in hand
chris's um you want to miss it's
happiness is happening
i believe that grant mccloud had a
meeting with um
brinkhans site last friday
morning thursday morning um to talk
about that among
other things and get away forward for
the life for the license at the moment
it's actually sitting with
the property unit to make the final
uh changes to it and uh it should be how
far away grant do you know
okay so we'll get another update we'll
be happy to send that to
the cnr members and obviously we'll be
keeping brent informed along the way
thank you yeah there were a couple of
things but it wasn't a straight roll
over because we were them there was a
they requested a toilet which was a bit
debatable and also a
um the rights to put a building there
which had to be
sorted through so we're working on both
those and as chris said it'll be
happening pretty soon which will be good
because it has been embarrassing how
long it's taken
thank you um we're done with four
we have no deputations we're up to the
report 6.1
simon have a seat
in grant
well it's a long table sorry i know
afternoon everyone um so uh this report
is
to appoint a fee waiver subcommittee
to look at fee waiver applications for
community facilities
uh as you'll know there was a
update to the fees and charges policy
um which decided to
set a subcommittee of cnr to review
fee exemption waivers this was currently
previously being done on a report basis
to this committee so to expedite the
applications
it was to decided through the policy to
set up
a subcommittee um so
today it was um just to
nominate and appoint members to the
subcommittee
with councillor duty being one of the
pre-ordained members as she support
fellow holder for community facilities
and then part of this is to delegate the
authority to the subcommittee
to review the fee waivers
who's putting their hand up wendy's
there of course anyway
phil robbie
robbie and phil everybody happy with
that
the mayor moves the second up nikki
seconds robbie and philip
um fill those two positions
um i i don't need to put that as a
separate motion
moving it okay with so with those in c
would you like to move the the whole um
recommendations a to
g let me second that again nikki
dan just briefly to say that this is a
really good outcome we worked on this
last term of council
and this seemed to be the best way of
going forward we spent a lot of time
investigating the appropriate way of
setting up fees and charges and to get
in into a system we
looked extensively other councils and
other examples and where we got to i
thought was probably the best
it was the best way we could find that
could manage an appropriate way that
also protected our staff from being
directly involved and the setting fees
i think it was and also
having a smaller subcommittee to come
together in this way i think is the
appropriate way and council duty was
involved as was council barn that last
term
um when we were discussing that so i
think with council the duty of the issue
will be well aware of how we set that up
and the two
councils there i think will be really
really add to that so that's
i'm really appreciative of that can i
just say in general um simon i just had
some feedback up the street from
where we've had to cancel bookings and
all that
and we're really impressed with how you
and the team have been dealing with that
um and passed on to me just how easy
and great we've been to deal with uh
and so i just wanted to pass that on to
you
so thank you for your role and that
because that's really good feedback from
someone i didn't know that just took me
up the street
to mention that to me so thanks very
much for what you've been doing in that
process because
it's at times like this when we're in
difficult circumstances that people do
judge
our accounts on how we treat people so
that's really good service so thank you
you're dan for those comments nikki
speak to that not much to say other than
i think that this is a
fantastic idea um the structure and the
reasons behind it
i fully endorse and i think that this
will be a great committee it's
representative
of three different awards and
um with some some great people on it so
i wish you all the best
anyone else robbie thank you i've been
involved in several times and
and looking at the policy regarding
regarding this
and most of your recall i actually
opposed
and the last term of council
the the application of this but
nevertheless it's in
uh it cost us 40 plus thousand
and uh and i want to bring some scrutiny
back into the
into the process
obviously i was involved in the last
committee that had a look at this
i just want to note that in terms of
community development we've already had
some seminars on social recovery
with covert and that we're going to find
that groups are
having less and less potentially money
to be able to put forward
the way to keep a community connected is
through social connection
so i think it's absolutely essential
that our community has the opportunity
to use our community facilities
and the cost of not doing that is
actually going to be higher so i really
encourage the committee to look very
carefully at the ability to pay
which is what we discussed last time
obviously groups that can
pay should pay but those who can't and
are doing a service to the community
with their voluntary work
definitely should be considered
uh good afternoon everybody um so look
cast anglican
uh cemetery the church actually came to
us and and quite as to whether or not
the council would be willing to take
over the
maintenance and management of that
cemetery as well as the ownership of it
as you can appreciate the population of
the church there um starting to age
and it's an asset that they still value
but
the practicalities of them looking after
it are diminishing with
the aging population they've got within
their own congregation
we've had a look at uh how much it would
actually cost per annum so
you'll see there that one of the options
um and the staff recommendation
is uh three thousand seven hundred
dollars to
um maintain that per annum um
there is a another option there in terms
of we would grant them
um a similar sum for them to actually
look after it themselves
um however as i've said you know
obviously for the longevity of the
church and for the certainty of the
cemetery within the area
their preference was for it to come over
to council ownership
it's worth noting as well through the
report that you'll see there's
a reference to the cemeteries and burial
act that's currently going before
parliament
one of the aspects of that particular
change in legislation is that cemeteries
such as this would come over to council
if churches or any kind of private
owners of cemeteries do actually become
defunct or
to the point that they can't look after
them anyway so there's a good chance
that if that legislation passes through
these sorts of things will naturally
come over to us as a local district
council
to look after in time with some of those
cemeteries as well so
happy to take questions on the report
just two questions have you received any
indication as to whether or not they
would consider
non-anglican burials to be on that site
that's not a question that i have posed
to them chris i don't know if you'd had
any
further conversations with them around
that um i haven't received any feedback
about that
but if we were to take over the cemetery
and it was in council ownership then
we don't have a denomination based um
areas within our symmetries anymore the
only areas that we actually set aside
uh for the rsa i believe
um so would it default to that we would
have to have a conversation with them we
have absolutely every right to have
denomination areas within
our um so we'd have to have that
conversation with them at this stage
this is around um sort of a
principle-based um
approval um they still have a process to
go through themselves as to whether or
not they want to actually pass this to
us um so it's really an indication as to
whether they should
you know it's worth them even going
through that process themselves and if
they decide to
um then we could start even those
further conversations
yeah the reason i ask is just because
for the purpose of
voting on a resolution i'd like to know
because
if they are not amenable to that then
obviously it
makes better sense to to give them
the funding and otherwise um and to do
with what they wish and perhaps the
membership may change over time and
enable them or not and revisit it
otherwise
but my other question would be what are
the implications if the community
expectation of maintenance standard
changes
um as a result of council takeover like
how do we justify a lesser standard than
the urban
centers um at the moment um you're
talking about a lesser
standard in the cemetery so sorry
um well it would be it would be through
our levels of service anyway so
um i don't i'm not sure that we would
have any
any reason to up the standard that's
currently there
this is a small cemetery um the main
there is a another cemetery in cast
which is off chrysler
it's either avenue or lane i can't
remember what's called
denominational i don't know what the
capacity is there in terms of
but it's a very big area and so they
cater for all
all faiths and and non-faith as as well
out there but this is just a small
remaining area but that's probably a as
chris has indicated a
grand conversation with um bernard and
others up there around that point but
there's plenty of capacity in the other
burial area yeah
i'm not sure if i perhaps got a conflict
of interest because i've got family
members in there
no i thought i went there the other day
just checking to see if they're still
there
um but my question really is um
there is quite a long driveway which i
think
if it serves me right i think someone
used to graze his sheep along there
is it correct or not because that keeps
that tidy
um i'd have to i'd have to look into
what side leases or anything like that
that they've got but i'm not
i'm not 100 sure on what the grazing
regime is there could well be that
there's somebody grazing out there
yeah there's there's a picture in 3.5
yeah and you can see in 3.5 that there's
a
there is a track yeah there is um but
there is a fence also along there so
half of the space at the moment is just
looked after by the adjacent farmer
and if the council was going to look to
take it over
we would formalize that through an
agreement but we wouldn't be wanting to
take that off the farmer
at any stage until it was actually
needed for for burials
if we were to take it over we would
pretty much run it as it is
unless the expectations in the community
changed around how we were operating
their cemetery but
it is quite small there's not a lot of
burials um
and we'd be happy for the farmer more
than happy for the farmer to continue to
to look after the bit that he currently
does
yeah it's okay now it's a lovely little
cemetery
and very much respected by
people
[Music]
ah thank you um i just wondered what
would happen to the records
the existing records of the cemetery
who's there
and who would be keeping those records
if we were to take it over
uh yeah so i mean the church would still
have some form of role to play
and that's something that we'd have to
work through as well with them so
they've
in essence still got to talk to their
church trustees and also their bishop
around how this would actually work so
we could
we could actually talk about some of
those things with them in terms of how
that information would be transferred
over
we'd certainly wanting to keep it though
in terms of a public record for who was
there and and so forth because that's
that's important historical knowledge if
nothing else
and and i'll second it moves windy
seconds
down um being at kingsbury approached me
about this about 12 months ago
uh and it was at a point where grant met
with me
uh with vernon on-site and it was at a
point where
ben is just getting the point where it's
just getting a bit much for him um
and he's got she's involved in so many
different things up there being the
sexton for
this was just something he was finding
to be a bit of a drain
uh in mowing it an upkeep of that
so personally i'm supportive of this i
think it's
a sensible thing to do i think nikki
raises a fair point around
um denomination and whether that would
still remain if it's in our ownership
and that's a matter i guess that we
would need to
have conversation with the church
prophet well our staff would with the
church property trustees and ultimately
the bishop
um because it's the essay i i suppose in
the handing it
over but in principle i i approve us
um taking over the ownership of this and
responsibility
uh it's makes sense and as grant says
um in time and not too distant future we
wouldn't have a say in this in any event
because it would just automatically
transfer with
if the bill goes through parliament so i
think this just makes sense and relieves
a burden on somebody who's
does a huge amount for our community and
we're very lucky to have
the services of bernard and other
members of the community that do so much
in cast
yeah thank you i concur with that and
and really
should this go through i think when the
council needs to give a big
you know a letter of thanks to bernard
for all his hard work he's
put in there over the years it's um he's
keeping it in really good condition
thank you thank you
i'm quite happy to support this i just
wanted to make sure that it felt like it
was the right thing to do
for the communities involved so um yep
happy to vote for that
anybody else dan summed it up pretty
well
i mean there's only two options to take
it over or wind up giving them a grant
to maintain it
and as we've as we've covered the the
government are likely to force their
hand anyway so it's a bit of a
no-brainer
would you like the right of reply your
worship
i'll put that for adopt adoption then
all those in favor say
against carrick thank you
6.3 thank you grant matt
hiding round the corner i presume you're
still hiding around the corner
we are in your hand
thank you so uh as always the purpose of
this report is to update the community
and recreation committee
on the year-to-date progress for
aquatics um it's important to note that
this report was written
prior to going back into level two so
there is quite
a few things that are slightly different
at the moment um the transition went
relatively smoothly with staff and
customers already
largely familiar with our level two
operation and restrictions
this has seen us instigate the standard
requirements around contact tracing head
counts
and physical distancing but also some
specific things to aquatics
like restrictions around access to
changing rooms
programs including acrobatics and learn
to swim
like unlike previously we've been able
to continue operating acrobatics
classes following discussions with staff
customers and other facilities
these club classes now have a limited
class head count to ensure that we're
able to maintain
uh appropriate distancing within the
pool in the changing spaces
and as in the previous situation to
ensure compliance with physical
distancing
we've paused all lower level learn to
swim classes which involve direct
physical contact between staff and
customers
the tutors who were to be teaching those
classes have either opted to take leave
or been redeployed to assist the council
efforts
and contact tracing in other areas of
the business
back to the report in 4.3 we are seeking
further support for community groups
looking to run events at the aquatic
facilities
we're proposing a 25 discount for
qualifying groups which would address
this demand
with limited overall impact on budget as
this is not a key part of our business
with between five to eight after hours
pool highs events any
happening in any given year uh in
4.4 it details our plans around an
upcoming program maintenance closure at
kaiapoi aquatic centre
as noted some of this work has already
been addressed during the level three
stage
of the previous covet event
when ministry of health requirements
allowed us to have contractors on site
but not customers
the majority of these works relate to
remaining relate to the
repair of the main pool shell tile
surface
where grout is worn away which creates
the potential for tiles to start lifting
following the drafting of this report a
further contract and meeting
was held and we now have updated dates
as
opposed to what appears in the report
before you
this is this has pushed the work out by
around about a week
so um in recommendation e it says
notes a program maintenance closure at
kaiapoi aquatic center
between 5 january and now that would be
january so it's a couple extra days of
full closure
and then with limited levels of service
until 5 january 2021 which is an
additional week
i'll take the rest of the report as read
and i'm happy to answer any questions
just with regard to the groups and the
volunteer organizations etc
what that'll be pretty much local would
they
also the right great powers so um
uh this is for the the hot the after
hours pool hires
yes so um the one that jumps to mind is
the uh volunteer fire brigade
uh was the most recent pool hire
hello matt could you just clarify the
dates i didn't quite
match them up that was in 6.3 a
the period the kaiapoi aquatic centre
will be closed
absolutely so um notes a program
maintenance closure at kaiapoi aquatic
center between
5 january and 16 january so
i think it said 13 january yep so that
pushes
that first full part of the closure out
by a couple of days
and then so during that time the work's
done are
going to be not they'll be prohibitive
to having customers in the space
then the remaining period we will have
some pool space open
for leisure swimming and the like
through to
5th of february when we will reopen the
main pool
sorry just following that up how busy a
period
is january for the poll
generally not really because a lot of
people travel um
as well as having dudley open we can
manage a lot of that space through that
time
generally it's a time when people do a
lot of leisure swimming
and um i'm not sure how familiar you are
with the site psychic hypo
there's limited leisure opportunities
there so um generally it's a time we see
a lot more demand for the leisure side
of things up at dudley pool
okay my question really is carrying on
from this
are those that people that are going to
be affected by that do use it and they
need to go up to
dudley um how can we accommodate them if
they can't really afford to
do that travel
that's a good very good question um we
it's quite easy for us to
um pause memberships and that sort of
thing obviously that doesn't allow them
to
to so that when they come back they can
have an additional time on their
membership and
in card like that um off the top of my
head that would probably be the the
simplest way to address that
um there will be space in the leisure
in the leisure pool however it's a lot
shallower so whether it's appropriate
for the tasks
is is a bit more situational
um thank you for that if i can if i can
just add to that um
we absolutely have to do the closure and
it's always difficult to know exactly
when to do the closure and
there's been lots of cnr meetings where
we've proposed dates and there's been
debate around those dates because
generally we propose the second week of
the school holidays i believe as the
date and
that's one of our quiet times because i
don't think we have the noon swim going
which is uh when the pool's particularly
busy but it ends up being that
recreation time so
madness team did quite a bit of work to
try and identify a time out of
the usual when we do have a really
really low
occupancy in the pool and that is around
that january time where
the kids are not at school while it is a
little bit of recreation and
it is one of our lowest use times in the
pool so the alternative would be to move
back into
school holidays and do it in the second
week of the school holidays
but there is more people that will be
using the pool then
no i'm happy happy if we can recompense
them in some way
thank you
once again thank you very much matt um
really appreciate
your honesty and integrity in this and
thank you
yeah just with regard to my question
obviously
a discount comes at a cost and
hence the question the rate pairs that
use and then
and they're attracting the uh the
discount so it falls back onto the the
general
rate if um as pools are a hole into the
ground into which you
pour money but they're a necessary thing
to to have given that
we're surrounded by water etc um
hey i'll put 6.3 in for adoption all
those in favor say aye
thank you the community team
social recovery update report provides
an overview
of community team activity related to
key covert 19 social recovery project
areas and in particular details
uh progress towards the development of a
more
food secure district and alongside that
the potential development
of an associated community hub and
you will note that staff will present a
briefing on the food security and
hub project at the conclusion of this
meeting
[Music]
so also of particular note is the recent
acquisition
of 690 000 in ministry of social
development
funding towards project development
and also that both russia foundation
and department of internal affairs have
indicated
their potential support towards funding
the completion
of such a project
as detailed uh consideration
must be given to the resourcing of
facilitation for this
and other social recovery priorities
that sit outside of existing
community development strategy
priorities and it is important that we
don't lose
the support that is given to the rest of
the community that we retain strong
community across the district
staff are preparing a report detailing a
proposed collaborative option ensuring
that appropriate and timely utilization
of this considerable funding
as well as ensuring the appropriate
planning and resourcing of associated
recovery projects
and this will be presented at the
september council meeting
i'll take the content of my reporter's
read
highlighting in particular the
significant community support for the
social recovery of our district and
you'll see this evidence by the response
to
the social and community sector surveys
and also the breadth of representation
at the recent social recovery forum in
wood end
you'll also see that each of the social
recovery priority
issues directly relate to project lines
and the draft waimakariri covert 19
recovery strategy and that a strong
evidence-based has been applied to
identifying
and informing action related to these
priorities
um mentoring skill sharing
and opportunity inclusion for all
residents
both social and digital
and connection including increased
collaboration for better
local outcomes
in terms of collaboration we've seen
a very recent example with a
collaborative response to a key local
issue resulting in the willingness of
salvation army and city mission to work
together
to ensure the maintenance and
enhancement of local drug and alcohol
counselling provision
and this has been a key concern for our
district where we look to
have a significant reduction in
in such provision right at a time where
it's anticipated that we will see
increased dependence
on alcohol and drugs as the
mental health effects of of the covet
incident take effect
community team staff continue to work
through a range of networks
alongside our key partners to build
formative evidence
and facilitate appropriate community
lead responses
i'm happy to answer any questions in
relation to my report
in relation to the north canterbury um
model railway club they in the pamphlet
you provide that they weren't
mentioned in there my understanding is
that they were
still keen to be part of that discussion
albeit that they would prefer to be in
rengura
they still wish to be part of the hub
consideration that was their submission
during the annual plan just welcome why
they were
admitted from any reason why they were
admitted from the
document i i wonder whether that might
better be addressed um as part of the
briefing i think uh green space staff
are more up to date with i guess i'm
happy to hold i'm happy to hold
it
under your umbrella with community
welfare at kaiapoi
community community board in kaiapoi
last night that was mentioned as made
of grape of grey powers concerns that of
the
diminution of services to their members
um resulting in some quite severe um
problems like uh caregivers being
dropped from three or
three times a week to one a week and
caregivers
not coming who were doing the shopping
and people going home are you
specifically to grey power are you aware
of that yes we are
and and that has been discussed through
the health advisory group in various
other networks
um the the understanding at the moment
is that there is a gradual
reintroduction
of such services and i've i've seen
evidence of that
anecdotally the the provision of things
like housekeeping
the feedback that we had from the
general practitioner and nurse
practitioner at the health advisory
group was that
there was almost a blanket provision put
in place when you
got to a certain age and that this is
being reviewed in some cases there has
been a reduction in capacity with one of
the
service providers and so we're
kind of looking into that at the moment
so yes we are aware of it
i'm not sure if it's appropriate now or
later but
in the briefing satisfy food rescue did
they apply for the funding
and if so what was the funding they
applied for to be used
for i think that will fit really well
with the briefing
they were they were one of the partners
that were involved in discussions around
the application to that fund
thank you very much for this thorough
um
committee report i really very much
appreciate
it there's just been you've had so much
work to do
in the last since covert started and you
can just see how much the committee
your team is doing um to
bring us through this so i appreciate it
the question that i want to ask as well
please is
how how are you going for um volunteers
now with all this is it they coming back
up again or are you still a bit tight
the volunteer sector so the this um
social and community
sector survey identified that some
groups are
still experiencing a reduction in
volunteer capacity
and it appears that
that is in relation to older volunteers
uh being stood down
during the covert event and
reconsidering
their availability so there's quite a
bit of work going into supporting the
volunteer sector to attract
volunteers
[Music]
and to also make sure that that they can
retain volunteers
thank you
tessa just uh commend you on the uh you
and the team on the social recovery
planning forum last week that was
excellent
um and uh certainly feedback i've had
from
people that went along we have certainly
enjoyed it and got a lot out of it
i think you're in your team and you you
know have my thoughts in this space i
think you're doing an outstanding job
and
um certainly very pleased with the
leadership that you're providing so
thank you
uh you and your team in this area i
think it's really great that um
this we're going to just discuss it
further in the forum around
that funding that's come through for a
hub i think that's a
it's a really good option for us and and
certainly in terms of hubbing with
satisfied food rescue and that i think
that's
a really great opportunity and noting
that others are
likely to step other funders are
interested in that which
presents a really good opportunity for
us the issue that
council blacky raised before around grey
power
there has also been raised with me and
i've written a letter to the
district health board which was
supported
the health advisory group and other um
bodies locally member of parliament as
well that set up a meeting
uh in the uh to discuss that issue i had
a meeting with jan pentecost last week
who's the president of grey power
i've agreed to help her further
in other discussions with providers um
she just needs a bit of support and a
bit of backing and i'm happy to do that
because
that provision of care that's been that
is provided for people actually keeps
them in their homes
and means that they're less likely to be
going into other environments or making
choices to have to move out of their
homes or out of the health system so
it's quite critical enough that funding
isn't provided well that support isn't
provided it
has quite serious consequences for
that age bracket and um i certainly
whatever i can do to support it i will
i just wanted to mention um as well that
we had a very generous offer come
through today
from the um
hubei government via the hubei
government in china and they're going to
donate
2 000 face masks to our district
and so they're coming to present those
on thursday and i've
mentioned to tessa this morning it'd be
nice to find a way that we could
um distribute that to community groups
and those that need them so it's a
really generous
offer to come through from the new
zealand hubei
economy trade culture association which
is the official title but
if we can find a way to our food banks
and other areas to distribute those that
would be really great
so it's nice to have a positive come
through
all the other things that are going on
at the moment so it's nice to have some
generous benefactors but thanks again to
you and your team for what you do
thank you
kyoto koto um i'd like to
give you an update on libraries and our
activities
uh and since we last met in june um i'll
take the report as largely read
and like to draw your attention to just
several points in the report
starting with 4.1 kidsfest 2020
to some it might just look like a school
holiday festival
but to many it's been a long-running new
zealand-wide
festival that draws together parents and
children with largely free activities
now when covert appeared read its head
in february
all this central coordinating was paused
when we
were confident that we would be able to
run our kids first activities
through waimakariri libraries the
library's team kicked into action really
quickly and our newly
evolving culture of agency ideas and
action
and set up a team of largely customer
service library assistants with no
leadership responsibility and they
organised and delivered the whole thing
we had stunning mystery trails which
were themed who was the most fearsome
pirate in the seven seas we had craft
nights family quiz nights
um and all in all there were 14 sessions
with 761 children and 200 adults
from across our district i went to the
kaiapoi quiz night and there was a
family there
who live in shirley and for three years
in a row they have come out to the
kaiapoi event because they
us they love it so much we had family
visiting from albany
with locals in the district who were
brought along to the event it's quite a
thing
um the rangiora and kaipoi quizlets were
so popular that they needed two sets of
questions
and it was sold out two weeks in advance
well sold out it was free
some families trying to double dip and
attend both and win the prize
hence the need to change the questions
at both venues
um the best quote of kidsfest was what
the girl a little girl
and the family from the rangiora's
winning team
who said this is the best day in my life
and she'd won a family pass to sport
susie
for her family and i'll hand on hart
say that the kaiapoi event i've been in
libraries for 36 years and i have never
been
to a community event that was free
that was so memorable and so special and
the genuine feedback
from the participants was incredible
we're using these sorts of events to
grow leadership in our team as i
mentioned
so that even if you have an unnamed
position
untitled position you still have
leadership opportunities for your cv
if i can point to 4.3 you might be
interested in our ebook usage now
understandably covert had a dramatic
effect and impact on
our district's reading habits and when
we compared data
from february 219 to april 2
20. we saw that it had skyrocketed 394
percent
we understand that and the why our usage
has dipped a little bit but we met
we've been gathering our data quite
carefully and we're really surprised to
see
many readers continuing to read a and
print
borrowing both our most dynamic
platforms
which are overdrive which trades as
libby
and belinda australian vendor trading as
borrow box
have absolutely skyrocketed and data i
just grabbed today
shows that active users are up 166
on the same period last year ebook loans
are up 278
and reserves are up 223
we're using the collective power of our
canterbury consortia
and platform consolidation and making
vendors work for their money to get the
best value
in our really in a very very competitive
market
we've been 4.6 refers to promoting
reading into
interacti now lianza the library
association
ran a national books alive program
recently which i'd like to note to start
our mia dan
as uh our celebrity reader and we've
been proud to also be
celebrating reading into maori as part
of these awards
takorapunamu award recognises and
celebrates written in
or translated into te omari
the tua kiwi education committee were
contacted about working together
to film virtual story times with the te
reo maori finalists
and libraries delivered copies of books
to them so they could decide on the
right approach for us
it was suggested that this would be a
great opportunity for
rangatahi youth and they suggested two
students
two sisters eden and my re-wee coach
couch were absolutely exceptional when
their mother is a leading educationalist
their confidence beautiful use of rayo
and openness to this collaboration was
really beneficial to the libraries team
and gave a very gentle nudge to those of
us who are learning today maori
to be more public with it lianza
books a live celebration that led on
from what
happened in lockdown in the virtual
story times
has gifted libraries a really tangible
opportunity
waimakariri libraries do to acknowledge
a tangible opportunity
linking with tonga to phenopha and
bringing to life the library's strategic
direction that we
celebrate to maori and honor trajo
within our community organizations and
programs
i'd like to acknowledge that this report
doesn't cover the most recent week of
covert alert level two so if there are
any questions around that but i'll take
your questions on anything
thank you paula that's what you call a
wow report
chris told me this morning that briefing
he had to limit how many success stories
you're allowed to put in there in case
we just
had one more well go on do it
okay so 4.7 was our diverse community
and
those of you who were on this committee
last year would
remember we signaled that we wanted to
develop closer connections with new new
zealanders living across waimakariri
richard sheppard our collections manager
has
looked at census data he's worked with
the migrants and newgamers team and
tessa's group
and interviewed consulted with talked
and listened
and result of that
ongoing conversations since about
november last year we're proud to say
that we have collections in hindi
japanese simplified chinese tagalog
filipino german and spanish
some of these are sitting in the
rangiora work room some of them are
still waiting to arrive
because of covert related shipping
delays
community feedback and the consultation
that richard
undertook suggested that people who want
these are also wanting
esol english as a second language
materials so we're catering for that too
this is all with an existing budget
planned last year
and it was if we were to sum up the
response and feedback from this
initiative
it's been quite heartfelt appreciation
for acknowledging their diversities and
cultures
excellent thank you questions of paula
wendy paula with the cover two coming
back come back again as
are the book bags coming back into vogue
again
what we've ironically the week before uh
covert hit one our team one of our team
leaders um began to look at all of our
processes throughout lockdown
including the book bags and we
established a small group to look at our
processes with fresh eyes
you know that the beauty of hindsight so
we've refined that's it's all still on
the website it's still
been promoted through social media if
people ring if people
are um in the library doing a literally
a grab and run which we've experienced
so
long answer yes still going just
refining and as of last friday i've
still had two new libraries contact us
wanting
our processes to be shared with them so
it takes it to a total of 17 district
libraries around new zealand
taking our the process that i just would
like is 4.2
with the toddler's times in oxford
library um
and the the uh little
building that was the little theater
which was built by one of the local
builders um is does that have his name
on or anything like to say that he has
um
he hasn't asked for that um but that's a
really nice idea
we um we're really conscious about using
local
suppliers as we're trying more and more
with what we're buying
um but that's a really great idea i'll
pass it on to jason we could get a
little plaque made
yeah i just think it's lovely it's
really really nice to do
yep no no problem
just wondering how you've found um
people responding to wanting to give
photos and information
about the full september commemoration
if you've had much input on that or if
it needs a bit of a rev up
we the resignation we have mentioned in
the back of this
was the person responsible for gathering
that
so there that was claudia foley and she
was our i would say resident
heritage star given the
volume of things being coming our way
with covert and adapting
nobody's picked that up at the moment
because those positions are being
advertised at the moment
i am looking for people if there is
anybody in the 119 people that have
applied
to have that heritage expertise whilst
needing a customer focus there's a quite
a unique skill set
i've been working attended the last all
together kaya boy meetings
and have offered two of my team to help
build together
a photo montage with linda and her
mother
they got back to me last week and said
that they're happy to do that themselves
and we've given some ideas around how
that curation could take place
uh outside of the 4th of september
uh hello paula i see you are dropping
the wheeler's
e-platform app um i i wasn't familiar
with that yet but
i'm slightly familiar with wheelers um
do they still supply the library with
books
they may bind them i'm not sure what
happens but sure so
wheelers wheelers um are very big in the
school library market
that's where their traditional value
proposition has been they've moved
into public libraries when i started
it was signaled that we were now we now
had three vendors
libby overdrive uh borrow belinda
and wheelers and the service that the
services that we were getting were
quite different markedly different um i
have a historical
professional relationship with man with
our vendor through wheelers so we
invited them in
to talk through the points of difference
we had there were concerns around
the app and the efficiencies of staff
buying things through
through their provision we've repeatedly
tried to
address this and give them an
opportunity
but value for money-wise we are getting
a much better deal when we're looking
at the other two we're not using any of
the book binding
um the shelf ready products
so it's been a long conversation and
long decision coming to
31st of october taking our
products to just two platforms but if
we're looking at
value for money and staff time also and
consortia buying power
other libraries do use those more
transactional services but we
we don't thank you the other question
i've had asked of me
um taking the bar um
a history of the port of kaiapoi it's
not
apparently i haven't checked it myself
kept at the kaiapoi library
but is housed at rangiora and has to be
requested
just seemed odd by a local history
about kaya poi was not kept at the
kaiapoi library i'll hand that to
richard
and wheelers also do provide that book
but um if you talk to me i'm sure i can
provide you with one too
thank you
i've got nothing to say it's pretty hard
to add to excellence
i'm simply just gonna say paula you're
my favorite over achiever i love reading
your reports
i love the passion and the zeal that you
bring with everything that you and your
team do
and i mean your trailblazers you're
absolutely
killing it and i take my hat off to you
and all of your amazing staff well done
yes i think the power of the team having
agency
we're seeing it those comments but um
under diversity i also want to say that
i approached paula with a particularly
difficult not difficult but a
tricky situation for a family and just
appreciated how open you were to try and
assist that family to or someone that's
going through some difficult times in
their life of
of identifying who they are and that
um the library may be a place where that
person may feel
safe so thank you for being open to that
and following that through
and up with that family i know they've
very much appreciated it so
endorse everything that's been said um
yeah fantastic effort from you and your
team but that particularly is something
that meant a lot to that family that
that was followed through so thank you
thanks
yes i'd just like to endorse the
comments of my
colleagues i think the library
that you run is fantastic and i've
learned a new word today
shelf ready it's a bit like shovel ready
so thank you for that phrase
thank you so potentially we apologize
some of this work will have been
completed since i got to my last update
from grant
and i've got it written down with some
um
so when i can reserve pegasus playground
safety surface replacement options
consider including alteration of the
slide bound and making this safe for
users waikiki beach toilet
near the surf club continuing
discussions with water unit over septic
tanks and pump replacement
hopefully putting into issues currently
there
victoria park toilets wallpaper damage
and replacement to include clear perspex
is anti-vandalism solution gladstone
park playground stolen lily pads swing
second time
new one is on order with log with logos
on it
king street roundabout replacement
planting programmed and post water unit
players
raven key toilet now demolish kaiapoi
wharf cctv installed in conversation
with local restaurant owner
terry tiriman at drive car park and
pickers that's the work we're starting a
couple of weeks ago
karaki beach car park works and was
nearing completion
all here is now chip sealed with minor
work still to be completed such as line
marking
mandeville retail village corner
bollards were being installed a week ago
as i understand it
and a head delayed project due to covert
dudley park lights now commissioned
operational available for community to
book
coyote artwork reinstatement progressing
with prices now received from contractor
expected to be completed in coming weeks
a consent
has been obtained from mandeville toilet
looking to go to tinder for both
mandeville and silverstream estate
toilets
as a package shortly that's me
in relation to the comment that just a
question chris actually
um mentioned about the toilet vandalism
have we
have we followed up with our insurance
company to see whether that damage is
actually covered
the value won't be enough the value in
the end only came to i believe
1400 so it's not enough
but we are still working with the
edge edsard is working with the police
and with the school
um and identify while they've identified
um who have done it and
looking at um what possible reparation
we can actually work through which at
the moment is not looking like um
involving the police and anything but
conversations which is really really
good
um and we'll look at the potential for
them to
work and silverstream reserve will do
something else to to pay off the
to pay off that money and if they're
happy with going down that route that's
really positive for us
and having their family involved if
they're not happy to go down that route
then the police have said they're happy
to deal with it
thank you um i just
really like to start off first and
foremost just congratulating
across your teams of the pools the
community team the library and the green
space
they are doing a fantastic job and i
very much appreciate the amount
of game
that's right um
i just want to mention about the
mandeville sports
club board um the strategic plan is
getting closer to being approved
that board does a
huge amount of work and and the team
that goes with them all the sports team
they just work beyond over and above the
call of duty
the mile which the council provided
funding for
is being put to good use and that ground
is looking really beautiful all the
areas where i've never been able to mow
because the mile was too big
is now looking really sharp that it
looks really tidy
and hats off to richard is doing a great
job
um they've also managed to tidy up the
boundary between the park and the
private properties where they'd come to
council
asking for funding um but and this was
done
with the generosity of a private
contractor and now
they can move on and get the walking
track and the planting
can go ahead in this area and they've
all talked about the toilet facility
oxford pearson park the fence is
the along the main street has been
repaired and is starting to look up to a
really excellent standard
this fence was built back and i think it
might be in the 1930s so it's actually
really important
part of the township history is that
correct the 1930s or not early after
don't know no i'll go and check it out
actually but i'm really pleased with it
starting to look really
really good um
the men's shed extension at the peasant
park
the pearson park advisory board gave it
the okay for this extension to be
done and these that the oxford men's
shed is uh they're just
paying for this to be to be built which
is wonderful
um stadium y macarei that walkabout we
had was
great it was just so good to have a look
at that stadium
and being able to actually visualize it
from right on the ground and rather than
just be looking about there
um the covert 19 social recovery
tessa and your team thank you very much
for that that was a very good
um get together on that one and
i'm sure you'll have a lot of work come
through from that yeah
um sorry for my my bag um
the cuss community center well um
hopefully that will be
um sorted out shortly it's been
but in the long run what a wonderful
facility it's going to be
um the mayor and myself and
the age friendly chair we went and spoke
to the blood clinic
in the ring euro regarding problems they
felt that there was
a lack of parking but uh and
we also had a discussion about you know
a couple of areas that where they could
may be able to park
but it was interesting um last week when
we were
at this age at this meeting
that people came up and said look we've
had no problems with that we can go in
there park
we were in and out of that clinic in
about five minutes so
um obviously it just must be working and
and working well
so hopefully we don't have any more
complaints from it
there and um
that's really it thank if you want to
keep going
just hear the point to that comment when
you made around the
blood cloth just to let um that was
really good summary wendy but
just one thing um two things i wasn't
aware of there's two car parks at the
back they're going to convert those
to be available for the currently used
by staff they're going to convert those
to be available to those who who may
need to use them and also look
for other parking solutions in the area
the other point is that if somebody is
in in need and isn't able to get there
their doctor is actually in a position
to direct a home
service for getting your bloods taken i
didn't know that so
i just just thought i'd mention that as
well so if you hear of anyone
that's vulnerable that isn't able to to
get down there then they
are able to go to the home and take
plenty so that they has to be through
your doctor
[Music]
[Applause]
you